alright let's talk about the internet
Huffington Post which is like the drudge
report for the other guys they are
banning anonymous comments CEO Arianna
Huffington had this to say trolls have
become more and more aggressive and
uglier freedom of expression is given to
people who stand up for what they're
saying and not hiding behind anonymity I
actually basically think this is a
pretty good thing these message boards
and the comment sites and even what's
going on here on YouTube we'll get to
that in just a second has become a haven
for racists and anti women and
anti-semites and give me something else
anti-gay is homophobes thank you and all
kinds of just endless eight I do think
there's some reasons that this may be a
problematic because if you're in a
country that's not free and this is your
only form of expression that could be a
problem but let's just start with the
United States and the Western world in
the free countries is this basically a
good idea because all of this stuff it's
just crazy people ranting and raving and
you know a little something about
ranting and raving to meet or something
about renting it really I mean all you
have to do is go to youtube pick any
video clip go to the fourth comment and
the fourth commenter always viciously
rips the third commenters the fourth
commenters always a jerk what what is it
about number for it so it's always
starts with three like things related to
the video and then by four and then the
fifth guy comes in and tries to find
common ground between everybody and for
that the six commenter impugns his
sexuality so that's pretty much how it
goes um I don't you know what you kind
of get you I'm one of those guys that
I'll find myself getting caught up at
like an Huffington Post I'll make a
comment and then someone comments back
I'm like you little dick and then I'll
say something back before i know it like
I'm in a thing I'm like wow why did I
get in this ok so my policy on it is
that I will not even on twitter if
someone's just an egg if they're just an
anonymous egg I will not debate you I
just can't I can't debate an anonymous
thing you know to me but if you're a
person I'll engage I'll try to engage in
some sort of level of discussion you
don't even know if they're a real or you
know if they are who they say they are
so the anonymity thing half the time
that people are like anonymous you can
have
I'm bill green or whatever and you don't
know who the hell that is it's a big
picture fake person a you know and they
could start an account with another
email so i take that all with a grain of
salt anyways and people on Twitter that
I mean I just block them anyways I don't
even give them the time of day so it's
like I don't even I won't even go into a
debate with a troll who if they hate you
anyways in there spewing hate and they
you know that they're not even going to
reason or see your side and they just
hate you for whatever reason then we
move on what we've got it we've got a
couple numbers to look at related to the
hate online commenters thirty five
percent of the more anonymous and sixty
one percent uses pseudo name as far as
the anonymous commenters go thirty four
percent of them put out positive stuff
fifty-five percent put out neutral stuff
eleven percent negative do you think
there's some importance to having some
level of anonymity though because in the
bigger world when people need to express
themselves somehow and they can't
because of governments not that I mean
we know our governments watching us now
too so what do you think do I think it's
important yeah i think it's read first
of all their risk in taking anonymity
away from the internet i think it you
need to have anonymity yes and I'll i
will often um if i want to make a
comment i will often go under a sword in
him right or pseudonyms I don't even
know what that is and so yeah I will do
I think its input and you know what
anybody who gets offended at internet
comments you know needs it needs to go
back and slap their parents because they
weren't raised correctly right what's
wrong with you get up so you need to
decide I think it's great actually Leah
do you think there's maybe some reason
that all these people that are walking
around with so much hate and so much
racism in homophobia and all that stuff
you think there's actually something
positive the fact that they get it out
while sitting at their computer as
opposed to bottling it up and then doing
something crazy really efficient if
people are bottling up their anger and
their hate I just look at people that
that that right nasty things anonymously
are trolls anyways who they don't have
the balls to say it to my face and you
know half the time it's not even things
like they're afraid of their government
cracking down and then we're talking
about like people that are anonymously
bullying a girl in in their school or
something that's [ __ ] yeah
it's like meet me on the playground okay
pal that's how we used to sell it when I
was a kid it's like there's none of this
facebook [ __ ] there's none of this i'm
gonna do i'm going to start another
facebook page and you know there's a
small percentage of people that are
afraid to afraid of governments may be
afraid of workplace violence or
something that they're posting that they
feel like they need to get it out on a
comment section on a blog or I mean
really that's the important part of this
now yeah I was trying to make a
distinction between someone that lives
in a relatively free society and verses
there are places let's say in the Middle
East where maybe you need to be
anonymous on a message board so you can
argue against the regime but that's
totally on or Syria and you're trying to
get information out you're sneaking it
you're hiding in safe houses and you're
trying to get the truth out to the world
that's something completely different
but Jimmy do you have a message for the
commenters on this video because they're
going to be very upset with us no matter
what my message for them is that I think
they they're they're all very witty and
snappy dresser they love it they really
are you dressers snappy dresser yeah
what I know I think that that you know
what I didn't think about that the kids
being bullied that's different for sure
I agree with her on that uh but I just
want to say I think like when you see
like especially YouTube people are so
over the top correct like they'll just
be racist out of nowhere or just
completely never be that to your face oh
whatever so this doesn't help you i
think what i'm saying is i think it
makes me kind of laugh now so i think it
helps just kind of laughed that [ __ ] up
so those people don't get none arts
because that's all they're doing that's
what a troll is right that's an
interesting point that they're sort of
getting it out and you can it really
shows it's because it's typed and you
can look at it and read it again you can
really see how ridiculous and evil all
this race manali yeah you know what
sometimes you fall down the rabbit hole
I've done that a couple times and then
all of a sudden next thing you know like
a half an hour later you're still
looking at like this chain of comments
of people down here's like you so and so
007 you Sokka bubble you know and I'm
like wait which one what did he say
again you're trying to go back and find
what he's commenting on and just it's
not even worth my time I thought how
insulted could I be at a guy with a
screen name fart saver you know what I
mean exactly and on that note I think I
can speak for Jimmy Dore and leeann
tweeden when I say you guys are all one
full we love you and we have nothing but
nice things two things don't be and say
about you you anonymous wonderful people